en este vídeo vamos a vamos a elevar un
poco la dificultad en la multiplicación
pero sólo un poco no te asustes no me
quites este vídeo porque hemos estado
haciendo a ver multiplicaciones de dos
dígitos por un dígito 3 x por un dígito
4 por un dígito pero ahora vamos a
elevarlo simplemente un dígito más
entonces un número de 5 dígitos por un
número de un dígito entonces 64 mil 329
por que te parece un número sencillo por
el número 4 esto por 4 y el 4 va a
multiplicar a cada uno de los dígitos de
64 mil 329 el procedimiento no cambia
simplemente simplemente se hace un poco
más largo porque ya tenemos un número de
mayor cifras entonces iniciamos con esto
4 por 9 es igual a 36 ajá 4 por 9 es
igual a 36 pongo el 6 en las unidades en
lugar de las unidades aquí y llevamos 3
en el lugar de las decenas ahora
entonces ok perfecto sigue sigue 4 por 2
4 por 2 más 3 porque llevamos 3 entonces
más 3 y ahora por orden de operaciones
la multiplicación va primero
entonces multiplicamos 4 por 2 eso es
igual a 8 más 3 esto es igual a 11 esto
es igual a 11 pongo el 1 aquí y llevamos
1 en el lugar de las centenas ahora
vamos con con 4 por 3 entonces 4 por 3
es igual a 12 pero llevamos 1 entonces
más 14 por 3 es igual esto es igual a 12
más uno es igual a 13 baja pongo en 3
aquí y llevamos 1 ahora 4x4 4 x 4 es
igual a 16 4 por 4 pero llevamos 1
entonces más 1 más 1 multiplicamos
primero esto 4 x 4 es igual a 16 más uno
es igual a 17 el 7 lo pongo aquí y
llevamos 1
entonces ahora finalmente finalmente ya
casi terminamos 4 por 6 4 por 6 y
llevamos 1 entonces más 1 más 1
hacemos la multiplicación primero 4 por
6 es igual a 24 más uno es igual a 25 y
como como ya no hay más no hay más
dígitos por los cuales multiplicar así
va el 25 simplemente lo pongo lo pongo
completo aquí abajo por lo tanto 64 mil
329 por 4 es igual a 200 57 mil 316
ahora la coma la coma simplemente me
ayuda a leer el número ajá si tuviera
solamente hasta el 7 serían 7 mil o por
ejemplo si tengo otra coma después del 2
entonces estaría ya hablando yo de
millones pero simplemente me ayuda a
leer ahora vamos a complicar un poco más
esto hemos estado haciendo
multiplicación no te asustes hemos
estado haciendo multiplicación de varios
dígitos por un dígito pero vamos a
elevar un poco la dificultad simplemente
vamos a multiplicar dos dígitos por dos
dígitos y
es lo mismo simplemente es un paso más
entonces qué te parece si iniciamos con
el número
de dos dígitos 36 entonces 36 x
36 por 23 vamos a multiplicar 36 por 23
y vamos a iniciar con esta
multiplicación con este ejercicio
exactamente como lo harías si solo
tuvieras un dígito ignora este 2 por el
momento al 2 en el 23 ignora lo íbamos a
hacer 3 por 6 es igual a 18 entonces
pongo el 8 aquí llevamos una después
hacemos sigue 3 por 3 entonces 3 por 3
es igual a 9 pero llevamos 1 entonces
sería 3 por tres más uno más uno esto es
igual a 10 entonces pongo aquí el cero y
como ya no tengo dígitos en el 36
entonces simplemente pongo el 1 ahí
abajo y tenemos tenemos entonces que 36
por 3 es igual a 108 lo escribo 36 por 3
es igual a 108 ahora bien observa esto
tenemos este 2 que en realidad es un 20
porque está en el lugar de las decenas
entonces lo que estamos haciendo en
realidad es multiplicar 36 por 20
este 2 representa un 20 y para que
funcione voy a poner un 0 abajo del 8
aquí voy a poner un cero ese 0 lo voy a
poner ahí por una razón la cual ahorita
no te voy a explicar pero en el momento
te lo digo entonces hacemos con el 2 lo
mismo que hicimos con el 3 el 2
multiplica cada uno de los dígitos en 36
así que vamos con 2 por 6 2 por 6 es
igual a 12 pongo el 2 aquí y llevamos 1
pero aquí tengo este 1 olvida ese es era
con respecto al 3 por 6 igual a 18
entonces éste lo tachó ese no nos sirve
entonces lo que seguimos 2 por 6 es
igual a 12 pongo el 2 abajo en el lugar
de las decenas y llevamos 1 el 1 lo voy
a poner aquí y ahora vamos con vamos con
2 por 3 2 por 3 es igual
2 x 3 es igual a 6 más el 1 que llevamos
llevamos este 1 entonces se lo sumamos
más uno es igual a 7 el 7 lo pongo aquí
en lugar de las centenas y ahora tenemos
720 porque 720 ese 0 lo agregue porque
este este 2 no es un 2 este 2 representa
un 20 entonces estamos haciendo 36 por
20 eso es igual a 720 36 por 2 es igual
a 72 pero 36 por 20 es igual a 720 por
eso ese 0 lo puse ahí y recuerda este
este 2 está en el lugar de las decenas
entonces no es un 2 simplemente es un 20
muy bien ahora que sigue vamos a sumar
hicimos 36 por 23 eso lo voy a ver lo
voy a reescribir de otra forma en que ya
hemos hecho en otras en otros vídeos
entonces ok necesita necesito espacio
aquí pero
un poco ok simplemente hacemos la suma
aquí 80 es igual a 80 más 2 es igual a 2
y 1 más 7 es igual a 8 entonces 36 por
23 es igual a 820 pero pero porque
funciona esto porque funciona esto
porque funciona hacer 36 por 3 será
igual a 108 y después sumarle 720 porque
funciona eso ok esto esto se puede
reescribir de otra forma la manera
estándar sería la que acabamos de hacer
36 por 23
eso es igual a 720 pero se puede
reescribir de la siguiente manera 36 por
20 más 3 porque 23 es igual a 20 más 3 o
como está la propiedad distributiva no
sé si lo has escuchado antes la
propiedad distributiva nos dice que esto
es lo mismo que 36 por 20 más 36 por 3
ahora espero no te esté confundiendo
esta anotación simplemente es lo mismo
36 por 20 sabemos que esto es igual a
720 y 36 por 3 es igual a 108 sumamos y
nos da 828 828 es lo que obtuvimos sí
exacto ok perfecto estamos estamos muy
bien ahora amd esto lo puedo escribir de
la siguiente manera 30 más 6 por 20 más
3 y lo puedes de hecho lo voy a hacer
así yo lo voy a hacer de esta manera
entonces voy a voy a multiplicar
aquí tenemos 3 por 6 es igual a 18 y 18
es igual a 10 más 8 pongo el 8 aquí
abajo
el 8 aquí y llevamos 10 ahora estoy acá
ignorando por completo esto nos sirve
ahora 3 por 30 es igual a 90 más 10 que
llevamos es igual a 100 entonces lo que
voy a hacer es poner un cero aquí en el
lugar de las decenas y un 100 aquí sí sí
esto te está confundiendo cambia de
vídeo es otra cosa ve al parque por qué
por qué pero si no te está confundiendo
perfecto multiplicamos por 20 es lo que
sigue ignore este 10 y 20 por 6 es igual
a 120 pongo el 20 en el lugar de las
decenas ahí abajo más 100 que llevamos
entonces el 100 lo voy a poner aquí
pongo el 100 y 20 por 30 observa observa
esto 2 por 3 es igual a 6 y tenemos dos
ceros entonces al 6 le agregamos dos
ceros 20 por 30 es igual a 600 más 100
más 100 que llevamos es igual a 700
y ya hacemos la suma hacemos la suma
tenemos 800 más 20 más 8 es igual a 828
perfecto ahora todo esto todo esto
recuerda que lo he estado haciendo
porque te quiere explicar por qué puse
ese cero ahí entonces hagamos otro
ejemplo yo creo que haciendo más
ejemplos va a quedar claro porque lo
estoy haciendo y hagamos uno divertido
en esta ocasión vamos a hacer qué te
parece si multiplicamos 77 x por 77 ajá
entonces 7 por 7 es igual a 49 pongo el
9 aquí llevamos 4 llevamos 4 acá y 7 por
7 es igual al 49 4 es igual a 53
entonces 53
ok ahora ahora voy a poner un cero aquí
abajo del 9 vamos con este 7 pongo un 0
aquí ignoramos este 4 adiós a ese 4 y
vamos con este 7 7 por 7 es igual a 49
pongo un 9 aquí llevamos 4 7 por 7 es
igual a 49 más 4 es igual a 53 y ahora
no está no está aquí que 7 por 77 obtuve
539 pero 70 por 77 obtuve 5.390 ahora
simplemente vamos a sumar esto sumamos
90 es igual a 9 esto es igual a 9 ahora
a 39 es igual a 12 pongo el 2 llevamos
115 es igual a 63 es igual a 9
5 terminamos perfecto entonces es tan
sencillo como puedes ver nos vemos en el
próximo vídeo